[Music]
so let's go to aaron in allentown
and aaron you can join us on the train
wreck of a show that we are rocking and
rolling with today how are you
i'm good doctor john how are you i am
good
so good so so good so what's up how are
you
um i'm doing well first off i just want
to say thank you
your words have made an impact in my
life more than you know for the better
but first i just want to say thank you
you're so lovely thank you so so much
for saying that appreciate that
so what's up how can i help so i was
wondering and have been wondering for a
while
should i continue friendship if they are
draining to me
out of the gate i would just say no tell
me more about what you're thinking
so when i hang out with certain friends
like
um i'll enjoy my time but afterwards
i'll just feel like
a lot of energy just like got pulled
from me and i don't know whether it's
the person
me personally just how i process things
or
if it is the friendship itself that
needs to end
are these long-term friends or just
buddies this happened with everybody
tell me about
how you feel when you feel how you feel
it sometimes happens with everybody um
and it'll usually be like right after
i'll stop hanging out with them that
i'll like like okay wow that
took a lot of energy for me to just be
there and
hear all their information and process
everything they're going through because
life is heavy and for some reason a lot
of people tell me they're
heavy stuff so i just feel like i have i
have that to deal with
in addition to my heavy stuff right i
sometimes don't get to share
so do you have relationships in your
life that you leave
energetically that you leave fulfilled
um there are few and far between but yes
there are some
tell me about one it's with my mom
with your mom who's somebody who's
somebody that's not your parent
to be really honest i don't have one
that's not a family member
so when you go hang out with your
friends
your community members folks that aren't
your family members
what do you hope to get out of
that friendship that relationship
oftentimes i i just kind of want to
leave refreshed and be encouraged
um and sometimes i don't get that and
maybe that's an expectation
that is unrealistic to put on someone
else
um so what do you get from your mom
that you don't get from your friends
i'm listened to and i'm heard out
so here's my thinking
and i'm just going to talk out loud for
a second is that cool
yep okay so with
our parents they often not
not everybody experiences this but often
they'll doute on us
they will make the whole world about us
right and that feels so good
um but it can become transactional
meaning i go to them so that i get
something
and i think that can ultimately drain
friendships when you try to go to other
people for a thing
instead of approaching friendships in a
more of a service-minded service mindset
what can i bring to these this group of
people
and hopefully those people that only
works if they're bringing that same
thought to you right so we all have
friends or
community members or people that we know
that are vampires we show up with the
service mind attitude like
we bring drinks every time we show up or
we bring
food or snacks we make sure if we're
watching the fights we always bring the
money or whatever the thing is
and we bring funny stories and we bring
our challenges and hurts
and they bring theirs and everybody kind
of puts it on the table and that's what
friendship
is right it's it's what can i can i tell
you the good stuff can i tell you the
bad stuff and would you still love me
right and
man if you show up to somebody and they
don't reciprocate they just drain drain
drain
yeah that's hard that is so hard
i have experienced what you're talking
about one because i'm kind of an
introvert
i fall right on the line of the
introversion extroversion if you believe
any of that voodoo witchcraft which i
usually don't but
i'm more of an introvert i like being by
myself
i get um lifted up by that
but i found that when i hung out with
people and it was all about
me i left more drained why did i say
that
what did i say i can't believe i told
that story it was really
i was looking at those engagements as a
performance
did my audience respond in the right way
they didn't like that i said that i may
have exaggerated that story too much and
when i quit doing that and i just
started showing up being fully myself
and if somebody kept droning or whining
and i would say
hey dude just get over yourself quit
quit whining
and they would stop and then i would
tell my jokes and we would have fun and
we would engage and i would say how i
could support you
when i started just being fully myself i
quit leaving interactions that way
does that make sense that makes a lot of
sense yeah
hit home when you show up does it ever
feel like you
you're performing versus you just the
people around you your friends
just accept you for aaron
i i definitely do leave situations
questioning why i did certain things and
overthinking things ah okay i think i'm
realized
why do you do that why do you think you
leave
giving yourself a rundown of your
performance
i just feel like i always can do better
i guess i'm worried that i'm not gonna
be upset uh like accepted for
what i lay on the table too ah
tell me more about that
i don't know it's just life is messy so
why would someone want all of my mess so
it's hard to
kind of think when sometimes like i
don't want even all of my messages
so listen aaron 1 000
you're worth having friends and you're
worth being friends with
and the cool thing about having friends
in community is
when you've got more mess than you can
handle they're there to
pick up the other side of that couch and
when they've got more mess than they can
handle you're there to show up with
pizza and tacos
right that's what that's what community
is and it goes
seasonally right and sometimes your
friends are really in the thick of it
and it's awful sometimes you all
are and you just get together and you
just you're dumping
all of your boxes out on the table
that's why
um that's what wine was invented for
right
you sit there and you just work it out
then there's other times when
um you're gonna bring your positivity
here's a great example
and of how i think was it was a was a
signal that i've got a beautiful
friendship
with a guy that i've known for gosh 20
or 30 years now
my buddy he's the most stable guy i know
i may have even told this on the show
before he's the most stable guy i know
he called me do over a break
back in the fall and he said dude my
bank just got
bought i'm gonna be unemployed like i
think i'm gonna lose my job
and that was the same day that i had
gotten a call from my boss to check my
email and the email had told me that i
had just
made the best seller list i made number
two on the best seller list with my
little anxiety book and so my buddy
calls in his worst moment and he said
hey i think i'm gonna get fired and i
responded with i just made the best
seller
list and he responded with for your
little your little pamphlet book
and i was like yeah and then i said hey
you're the most stable friend i've got
you can't be fired that
rocks my world and so in a quick
exchange
i didn't have to hide the good stuff
that was going on in my life
he felt safe to tell me the crappy awful
stuff that was going on in his life
we made a few jokes and then when it was
over
he said man i'm really proud of you
you've been working for a long time to
be good at that stuff awesome
and i said hey man if i can help with
anything i'd love to have you all out of
the house we can just sit and talk about
this and share this in person
and they're actually coming to visit us
in a couple of weeks
so good friends don't have to hide the
good stuff don't have to hide the bad
stuff and they don't have to filter
themselves in front of their friends
and so backing out of that if you show
up to a house feeling like you have to
perform
i want to challenge you to turn that off
you show up and be full aaron because
the world deserves full errand
now there's parts of aaron that may be
super annoying and frustrating are there
oh yeah okay see me too i'm a lot
and the beautif the beautiful part about
having friends is they say hey deloney
how about you dial it back about 30
you're a lot right and usually they're
right
and we all laugh or i say you're an
idiot and they say you're an idiot and
then we get something to eat
right and then there's other times when
man aaron's gonna
bless that entire table right she is
going to be the person that can
with her quiet gravity can absorb some
of the pain people are feeling
makes sense out of some of the chaos in
people's lives and it becomes a gift
that only happens when you show up not
for a transaction not for performance
but just to be aaron with your friends
if after a couple of times you're full
errand
and they stop inviting you out or
you can tell that you're off-putting
they don't like you and man
yeah that's not your gang that's not
your crew right you're going to want to
find
other people to be in community with
or they may just roll their eyes and you
stay at the table and you say a dumb
joke and it lands
awful it's like a thud cthunk
and then you just say that stupid they
won't even funny joke and they're like
yeah that wasn't funny then you all move
on
and you're not thinking about at the end
of the day because that's your that's
your squad that's your gang
so yes go be with friends who are
driving you crazy
but only if you can be fully you and you
can drive them a little bit crazy
if you show up fully you shoulders down
you bring the foods that you think are
good
you're a hospitable person you welcome
people into your life and they just cut
you out
so be it their loss right and you can
also learn things from them too if
you're being a jerk you're being rude
which you're not
but if you are then you can learn some
social skills too
so show up be fully you if they don't
like that if that's not their thing then
cool there's gonna be a group of people
that
love aaron for aaron right and at the
end of the day should you continue
friendships that you find draining
no you shouldn't but only when you're
fully you if you're performing in this
training yeah it's exhausting right
theater's exhausting